(upbeat music)
- We have the opportunity to
work together with a variety
of different voices, colleagues
from all over the world
who have different
strengths that they bring,
different perspectives that they bring,
about life, and about
how the world operates,
and only when we bring
those voices together
will we have a more complete picture
about how the living world works.
So in order to really solve
the problems of the future,
we're going to need to work together
as a global community.
- Problems are not solved in isolation.
They're solved in collaborative
groups with other people,
and they're solved to be realistic.
So you have to consider not
just your own discipline
or your own science, but also
some economics, and ethics,
and other things that
relate to the real world
to help you reach a real
world, but sensible, solution.
So it requires combining
all those different ways
of thinking, being communicative
and problem solving
and working with other people
so that you can reach solutions
that actually benefit the world,
because some solutions are
gonna be great on paper,
but in practice, they
aren't really practical.
So that's why using new ways
of thinking to solve
problems is really important.
- As an example, for
me, in my PhD project,
even though my background
has been in biology,
the problem that really
captured my interest
and that I wanted to pursue
involves mechanics and physics.
And so it required learning a lot
of some deep theories and ideas in physics
that I wouldn't have thought of before,
and now I kinda approach,
it sort of changed the way
that I approach biological problems.
Now I have this physics lens
that I didn't have before,
and that expands the possibilities
of experiments I can think of,
or hypotheses that I could
have for how something works.
(upbeat music)